We've already discussed that Donald Trump
privately knows he can't win tomorrow.
I'll have a more detailed report on that for
you.
The the report from Peter Alexander is that
Trump realizes that he has no path to overturning
the results of the election, but he's doing
it as theater, the lawsuits, the fights, the
seeking and receiving financial contributions.
It's theater, but how is Donald Trump really
doing?
The speculation, of course, is that Donald
Trump is clearly damaged and triggered.
He's barely been seen in public since losing.
He did one press briefing last week where
he took no questions, simply saying I won.
He briefly showed up yesterday at a wreath
laying ceremony for Veterans Day.
And because we know about Donald Trump's narcissism
and being a sore loser and egomaniac, never
apologizing, never admitting defeat, one would
imagine that Donald Trump is not taking this
particularly well.
Well, The Washington Post's Philip Rucker
was on MSNBC yesterday and he's covered this
White House really well for years.
He has a number of of sources inside the Trump
administration.
And Philip Rucker says that the reality is
Trump is quite fragile emotionally right now.
Take a listen to this.
I don't think it'll come as a surprise to
anybody.
We haven't heard from the president this week.
We saw him today.
What's your reporting on where he is on his
personal journey?
Well, Brian, his emotional state is quite
fragile.
We've not seen or heard from the president
in several days, with the exception of this
morning on a rainy day in Washington.
He went out to Arlington National Cemetery
to lay a wreath in observance of Veterans
Day.
But he has not been doing much governing.
As best we can tell, he's actually fighting
hard to keep a job that he doesn't seem content
to do at the moment.
Rather, he's been lighting up the phones from
the White House.
He's been calling friends, advisers, allies
in what one official described to my colleagues,
Ashley Parker, Josh Stotsky and myself as
a search for good news.
She's just casting about for somebody to tell
him something good so he can hold on to hope
that he might still win this election, even
though the reality, the numbers are clearly
against him.
And he's starting to recognize that so much
so that he's talking about running again in
twenty, twenty four, which if he held on to
any and any sense that he was that these election
results were going to be overturned, that
he would be declared the victor, then he would
not be talking about a twenty, twenty four
campaign.
But here we are.
That is what he's talking about these last
few days.
So it all makes sense.
Quite fragile, barely leaving the White House,
doing no governing, calling people, searching
for good news to see if anybody might give
him some good news and thinking about running
again in twenty twenty four.
So I guess trumps feelings are hurt.
But remember, it's their side that always
says facts don't care about your feelings.
Isn't it time to buck up and accept the facts?
And this isn't just Trump.
This is the entire write and say that he lost.
They lost.
That's it.
And there were I saw this hilarious tweet
yesterday.
Who was it that it was like a both sides thing?
Oh, it was Howard Kurtz, who I think now does
like a media analysis show on Fox News, which
is hilarious in principle.
But Howard Kurtz tweeted, both sides see.
And on one side, you had Trump alleging that
he really won and then and refusing to allow
the Biden transition to officially start.
And then the example of the left was that
Whoopi Goldberg, I guess, said Trump, Trump
supporters have to suck it up, saying, look,
both sides hold on a second.
One side is the current administration refusing
to accept that they lost a presidential election
and interfering with the president elect's
transition?
That's one side.
What you're comparing it to to say both sides
are doing it is Whoopi Goldberg saying random
Trump should just accept that Trump lost both
sides.
Give me a break.
And I was again reminded of that right wing
refrain.
Facts don't care about your feelings.
These are facts.
Guys. Trump are going to need to suck it up
and accept the fact that Donald Trump lost.
And at the same time, at some point, Trump
is going to have to accept that Joe Biden
is president of the United States.
It could take months into Biden's presidency
before Donald Trump accepts it.
Now, I do want to talk about one other thing.
I've not heard a lot of discussion about this.
We do have a national security vulnerability
right now that has developed.
The reality is that Donald Trump really hasn't
been doing his job as president for a long
time, punted on coronavirus.
He's almost exclusively been campaigning for
months.
There really hasn't been a president for a
while.
But we now have a more acute national security
issue because Trump is doing no work.
Trump reportedly hasn't been even receiving
his presidential daily briefing.
And when Trump was getting the PDB, he didn't
pay attention.
He didn't read it.
Sometimes he would get distracted by a TV
with Fox News in the back of the room.
But Donald Trump is also not allowing the
president elect Joe Biden, to start receiving
the presidential daily briefing.
Now, ideally, normally in every other transition,
the president is getting the presidential
daily briefing and the president elect also
starts getting it.
And that way you have a smooth transition.
When Joe Biden comes into office on January
20th, he's aware and up to speed about everything
that's going on, terrorism, national security
threats, et cetera.
We have a situation right now where for at
least two months, no one is really getting
the presidential daily briefing.
Trump is president.
He's not getting it.
Biden is president elect.
And on top of this, we have the report from
Philip Rucker that Donald Trump's emotional
state is quite fragile right now.
So if you're a rogue nation, if you're an
adversary, if you're an enemy, if you're a
terrorist organization, you know, there is
a window of vulnerability here for the next
two months and maybe for some period after
as Joe Biden gets settled and gets up to speed
on everything, the US is likely more vulnerable
than usual.
This is an invitation to do bad things for
lack of a better term.
It is globally known.
You need no sources.
You don't need to eavesdrop on anything.
It is globally known that.
Right now, there's a total absence of leadership
on national security.
Nobody's getting the PDB at the highest levels
of government.
Anyone who would want to do us harm can just
turn on TV and realize what's going on.
Very disturbing, all because of Donald Trump's
fragile ego and lack of willingness to formally
admit defeat and sign off on Joe Biden starting
to get the presidential daily briefing.
It's disgusting.